on thursday the stop economist fell
victim to facebook fact checkers when he
stated that the united states is in the
recession following the release of the
gdp report
which showed negative growth for the
second consecutive quarter the standard
definition of an economic recession we
live in an orwellian healthscape
facebook is now fact checking anyone who
questions the white houses
ward games about the definition
recession phil magnus wrote on twitter a
researcher and educator with the
american institute for economic research
how wild has it been that an economist
is being fact-checked by facebook tom
what do you think about that well i
think right now
we've got
the tech companies what are they scared
to death of they're scared to death of
congressional hearings and so they're
trying to play nice with washington and
i call this a softball from the tech
from thanga right this is just a
softball they're coming out there and
saying oh we're not really in a
recession because the white house said
we're not really in recession and
they're trying to play nice remember
facebook was the odd man out after the
election facebook took the heat and
criticism
from the dnc well you basically let
trump and let russia you were the guy
you were the ones who weren't really
watching your front yard remember all
those criticisms of facebook so i think
facebook this is nothing more than
facebook takes a zero risk thing of
creating a headline of coming back and
saying oh yeah yeah no we kind of agree
you know there's uh there's no recession
here and that's just ridiculous
everybody who's looking at all the
statistics that have been used for 50
years
does the technical statistics are out
we're in a recession and by the way just
ask anybody who's at the supermarket
what's going on right i think it's
pretty simple it's this is facebook this
is their they're trying to make money
vinnie what do you think about it just i
i i just think people are
just out of touch and the fact that we
let them get that powerful it's just
it's nuts and it's not going to stop and
then and then november's coming so it's
going to get even i can't wait i can
let's play devil's advocate let's play
devil's advocate is there anything wrong
with that adam is there anything wrong
with facebook fact checking and
economists saying he thinks we're in
recession right now
so just so we're clear the the economist
was saying that we're in a recession and
facebook the economist was saying we're
in a recession because of two quarters
in row of gdp being down and facebook
comes out and says no we're not on a
recession you know fact checking and
saying it's not necessarily the
definition i just i don't understand the
moving of the goal posts for
i i think i believe it was you that
posted a clip of bill clinton sitting
down i'm glad you said that can you pull
up the bill clinton clip from 2001 yeah
so watch i don't like the moving of the
goal post if something is a
representation by definition
here's what bill clinton said
it's the economy sitting next to a man
named george so what do you think about
a reception
well a recession is two quarters in a
row of negative growth i don't think
we're going to have that
but we couldn't keep up five percent
growth a year you know forever so
most of the i think 49 of the 50 blue
chip uh forecasters
but i think there'll be things to be
managed still have economic challenges
and uh you ought to give them a chance
to meet them and not try to figure it
all out in advance
does it look like the guy that that just
hooked up with look how happy he looks
and look how shitty george bush looks he
was definitely he was hooking up with
monica at this point right
look how happy he looks that's the guy
that's getting late not from hillary but
look at that look at that look at the
grin
this must have been that's the guy that
had two very rough years going into this
just 21 years yeah this was after he was
impeached but this was unhappy i assume
this was right at the transition from
the to the in 2000 to the georgia
technician
transition right exactly so in january
that's my guy by the way i mean he's
just look at how happy he's getting
[ __ ] or not i don't really care
he was happy he's a happy guy
he was smooth man i got to tell you but
anyway get to your initial point he said
it then i will say it again
if by definition a recession is two
quarters of negative gdp growth yeah it
is what it is and i will say that it
wasn't
disastrous gdp would have just come back
at uh 0.9 negative 0.9 so it's not
you know it's not crumbling but by
definition we are in a reception but
democrats on the recession side adam but
on the inflation side i think people no
doubt yeah
but it's not but that's inflation is not
a recession but that's just by gdp it
just seems like the left is they're
changing the difference on everything
the economy is not
run in reverse at a horrifying rate but
it is it is a recession but is it one of
the worst recessions on record not
yet yeah yeah but inflation is is rough
on the average person and that's what
sucks so i was having a call yesterday
with you know how they say if you want
to find out what's going you know
whether there's a recession or not you
go to what you know a few different
places by the way i love what manchin
said in an interview with uh
uh what's the guy from fox news the guy
that always has mansion breath bearer
yeah he said he says look
you know
17
nobel laureates said that inflation was
transitory you know and look what
happened to them and these are 17 you
know nobel prize
laureates that are talking about this
who still have jobs with linkedin who
still have jobs but they got up and they
said no this is transitory you don't
have to worry about it and this word
transitory yeah listen there's a few
words we learned in the last 12 months
okay one is transitory we learn about
entanglement we learn about there's a
few words that the definitions forever
change right and woman and woman doesn't
mean woman you think they can certainly
certainly certain words be just
but kamala harris border doesn't mean
border i could be a thousand miles from
the border yeah we've been to the border
we learned about the word insurrection i
wasn't familiar with that word
yeah doesn't even know what that means
but
but the point is the point is with the
you were talking about what you were
saying a minute ago you're saying uh uh
what point were you making you were
saying there's inflation there is a gdp
growth gdp growth but you were saying
something that prompted me to agree with
it agreeing with it with adam it was
that the recession is not like the worst
on record yet but but certainly
inflation is hurting the average person
let's talk about that and before what i
was talking about was facebook that they
were really trying to do a make good
with the us government and now and i
think they're even walking that back so
if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
[Music]